Kayla Cinnamon: Cool.
Well, welcome everybody.
If you're in the right
place, you're at the Build
and Ship Faster
with Developer-Optimized
Experience on Windows session.
My name is Kayla Cinnamon.
I'm here with Craig.
Craig Loewen: Hello.
I'm Craig.
I'm a Product Manager, working
on the Windows Subsys for Linux
and other AI tools on Windows.
Kayla Cinnamon: Oh, cool.
And Jianye as well.
Jianye Lu: Windows Performance,
and you'll hear about that.
Kayla Cinnamon: Perfect.
So, our team covers a bunch
of your favorite utilities
on Windows, obviously
Windows itself.
And then we have PowerToys on
our side, Windows Terminals
from our team, winget, the
Windows package manager,
and WSL, the Windows
Subsystem for Linux.
So, today we're going to cover a
bunch of updates that have come
across these utilities,
and we're going to get
into it pretty quickly.
We have minimal slides,
because that's our jam.
So, we're going to cover
building on Windows.
So, that's going to be when
you're building your apps,
but it's really the
improvements made to Windows
that are the things we're
going to be talking about.
And then also building
for Windows, that's going
to be everything we've created
to help make building those
Windows apps even more seamless
and even easier to do.
So, I think that's it.
We're going to get into some
desktop stuff right now,
so let's hop on over to mine.
Sweet. So, a lot of this was
in the keynote this morning,
but we're going to go
a little bit deeper
into some of these topics.
But first up is all
about developer setup.
So, when you're on Windows, you
got to go grab all your things,
Python, Node, all your packages,
all your favorite tooling.
And it takes a long time.
So, our team has actually put
together a winget configuration
file that does a bunch
of this stuff for you.
So, it installs Ubuntu, along
with Windows Subsystem
for Linux, along with tooling
like Git, GitHub CLI,
Copilot CLI, VS Code,
all of those things,
to make that step a
little bit easier.
And what's really cool
about these winget
configuration files is
that they're idempotent.
So, if you already
had Git, which
most of us, I'm sure, you do,
it's not going to
install Git again.
It's just going to make
sure that Git is there,
and then it's going to
move on to the next thing.
So, if you want to get this
today, we have a repo
that we published this
morning, we made public.
It's Windows Developer Config.
We will also have a slide at
the end with all of the links
and all the goodness,
so no sweat now.
But there's a few other things
that we're going to show today
that are in this repo, but
the config file is here.
And you can download it and see
what it's going to install,
and then you can run
it and go from there.
So, that's a quick way to get
your developer device set up.
And then some things that we've
added to Windows itself that are
in the insider program and
are shipping is some taskbar
personalization, in
particular, movable task bar.
So, this has been a
very popular request.
We're excited to bring it back.
Here's the task bar on the left.
You can put it on the top.
You can put it on the bottom,
where it's always been.
But yeah, thank you.
So, force of habit, I'm going
to keep it on the bottom
because I'm going to lose my
icons if I put it on the left.
But this is in the
insider program.
And another thing that's
coming is the new Run dialog.
So, very exciting.
So, this is Run.
It looks somewhat similar,
but a little bit more
streamlined of the UI.
And what's really
neat about this is
that it's built leveraging
the architecture
of PowerToys command palette,
which looks like this.
So, PowerToys had, well,
PowerToys had PowerToys
Run even before this,
which looked even different.
Let's see if I got that.
So, here's the evolution.
We have PowerToys run.
This came out first.
And then we evolved this
into Command Palette,
which has a bit
more extensibility,
more things you can
install into it,
a different UI
based off feedback.
And then this architecture
is now inside Run.
And you can search
for your tooling,
and it looks very similar
to how Command Palette
was, maybe just inverted.
So, what's really great
about that is we're
all about open source.
That slide I showed
at the beginning,
I think almost
everything on there,
except Windows, is open source.
So, if you contributed to the
Command Palette on PowerToys,
there's a good chance
that your code is now
in Windows, which is very cool.
So, that was vertical taskbar.
We have Run.
And now one thing I want to
cover, also open source,
is an experiment that we
are trying out that we want
to see how you guys like it.
So, this is
Intelligent Terminal.
And it kind of came from,
you know, we're working
with all these agents, but
when you go into Copilot CLI,
it takes over your
whole terminal.
So, it would be really nice if
you had a companion working
with you, so you could
still stay in your prompt,
but then have an agent
helping you along the way.
So, here's a regex command that
I asked an agent
to write for me,
because I don't know regex,
but I also asked it
to make it not work.
And the agent has detected
that it doesn't work.
This is meant to be like a
password verification regex.
And the agent is now thinking
about how to fix this.
And it should give me a solution
to create a better regex.
So, it's not giving me
a command specifically
because it doesn't know
my desired outcome.
Do I want to check for
an uppercase letter?
a unique character?
So, I can work with the agent to
come up with a better syntax
of regex without having
to leave the terminal.
And what's really cool is
when you first get Intelligent
Terminal, it's going to ask you,
like, hey, which agent do
you want to work with?
I only have GitHub
Copilot installed,
because I'm a
GitHub Copilot fan.
But you can add in Claude,
Codex, Open Code, anything.
Once you install
on your machine,
it should automatically
get picked
up by Intelligent Terminal.
And you can pick your
preferred model as well.
So, this is available today.
We want to get your
feedback on this, like,
how does this agentic pain feel
when you're working with it?
What kind of things
do you want to change
or have added to the experience?
We want to know.
So, this is open source.
It's on GitHub, published, I
think, this morning as well.
Everything is fresh
this morning.
So yeah, go ahead
and try this out,
and let us know how you like it.
But since we're on the
topic of terminal things,
I want to hand it over to Craig
to show a little bit more.
Craig Loewen: Yeah.
So, let's take a look at my
machine, and we're going
to take a look at
WSL containers,
also freshly announced
this morning,
and something we're
really excited about.
My goal today is
to convince you,
if you have never used
containers before,
why you might want to
get started using them,
and show you how you can do
all this with WSL containers.
So, we've added a new binary to
WSL called WSL C. I can go ahead
and run this, and I can run tons
of different Linux
container commands.
So, Linux container is basically
just a very nice little package
where I can run arbitrary Linux
binaries or distributions.
In this case, I just ran Ubuntu.
I ran the latest
version of Ubuntu.
But if I'm more of a Debian fan,
I can very easily just go here
and say, hey, give me the
latest version of Debian,
and then it will be able
to go pull it down for me.
Even though I didn't have that
downloaded, it pulled it down
and ran that, so I can run
that directly here
inside of my terminal.
Where containers get
really powerful,
and where this really
shows for WSL container,
is you can use this to build
powerful Linux environments
that you can share to
the cloud or locally.
And now this all works just
directly as part of WSL.
On top of that,
we have container
as an alias that's built in.
So, you can use either WSL C or
container, whichever is more
to your heart's desire.
So, if I go to this file here,
I have a "Container" folder,
and in it, I have some
different container files.
And so, what I can do is
actually build this image.
So, I'm going to build a service
directly inside of my terminal.
So, it's going to go ahead,
grab that image, build it.
I actually ran this before,
so everything was cached.
And if we go ahead and take a
look at that container file
with edit, great editor tool.
If you haven't seen this in the
command line, it's beautiful.
Works with your mouse, which I
-- probably my favorite part.
And if I go and take
a look at this,
I can see I'm grabbing Python
3.13, and then I am going
and running a bunch of
different Linux commands to set
up a specific Linux environment.
Now that I've built that
container, let's go ahead
and take a look
at it in my list.
So, I just ran WSL C, Image
LS, and then I piped it
to Grep and ran MarkItDown.
Well, hold on.
Piping it to Grep is pretty cool
because we have just released
Coreutils, which is a new way
to run a ton of different Linux
core utilities all directly
on Windows.
So, things like Grep are now
available as part of that.
I can even go ahead
and take a look at --
here, I'm looking at that list.
And then I pipe this to WC,
which counts the word count.
It's telling me there's 165
different tools inside of this.
So, let's take a
look at the list,
things like test.exe, tail.exe.
I'm personally really
excited about env.exe,
which shows your
environment variables,
because I only really know
how to do that in Bash,
speaking from
personal experience.
And it's just a super
awesome and powerful way to,
if you're a big Linux fan, like
I am, and you're a big fan
of bringing those
worlds together,
they can just coexist so nicely.
And so, let's kind of go
back to our example.
And I am going to run
that MarkItDown
service, which I built.
And so, I can go
and run that here.
And so, I took that
container that I defined
in that container file, and
then now I'm starting it up.
What you'll notice is
that I use this dash p
to say please take port
8000 in the container
and forward that onto Windows.
And so, now when I have
that, and I go to Edge,
and I go to local host 8000,
I get what that container is.
So, that container is defining a
very neat little web app for me.
That web app allows me to
go in and take any folder.
So, let's go and
find my samples,
which I have very conveniently
placed about 30 folders down.
Just 29 more.
Just 39 more.
All right, here we go.
So, there we go.
And then I can drag
and drop this in.
All this does is it takes any
PDF file or any file in here,
like dot doc x. So,
took this complex pdf,
and then it converted that
into markdown, and it shows me
that on the left
and on the right.
So, that could be my full
website contained right there.
I was able to go run that.
And so, if that
didn't convince you,
I think the last thing I'd
really show is you can do things
like light your whole
terminal on fire
by running different containers,
so that someone built that,
that you can go run with
just one command line,
a super powerful tool.
And I think it begs the question
of why did we build a
Linux container CLI,
when there are other
awesome CLI tools,
like there's Podman Desktop,
Docker Desktop, Rancher Desktop.
And the answer is these
are all great tools,
but we actually also built
an API for this as well.
And we're going to be
showing that in Part 2
on the building for Windows.
And so, we'll show that.
And because we wanted
to be opinionated
about how this would
work, like, for example,
we added this system
session command.
This doesn't exist
in Docker or Podman,
where we're being opinionated
about making sure
that these things, the API and
the CLI, can work together.
So, we knew we were going to
make some decisions like that.
That's why we created the CLI.
But the best part is
this is all open source.
We have tons of
improvements coming
to the underlying virtual
machine technology
powering this.
And those will all go to Docker,
Podman, Rancher, all for free.
For example, we are improving
cross-OS file performance
by two times when accessing
Windows files from Linux.
And so, something we're
really excited for.
And that is the whirlwind tour.
Let's jump back.
Kayla Cinnamon: Yeah.
Well, so actually, I pulled this
up while you were chatting.
The Coreutils that he showed
with all the 75 command line
utilities available on GitHub.
So, if you want to
go grab this today
and have all those utilities
right away, you can come
over to this repo and
download them from here.
And something else, like we're
talking about WSL and all
that stuff, something
else that comes
in this Windows Developer
Config is a comfort shell.
So, this is a customized flavor,
not flavor, but like a --
Craig Loewen: It's
like a customized
implementation of Ubuntu.
Kayla Cinnamon: There you go.
What he said.
Craig Loewen: It's
a setup script.
Kayla Cinnamon: Yeah.
So, it will come with
everything preinstalled
that you're familiar with.
So, if you're someone who
likes to use Homebrew or ZSH,
Starship, those kinds of tools,
we preinstall all of these
for you with that Comfort
shell, and it'll plug right
into your Ubuntu distro.
So, one of my favorites.
I showed this at the keynote.
But how cool is that?
It's btop.
So, this comes baked in along
with a lot of those other tools.
I think that's what we've
got for building on Windows.
We might want to do a little
recap, because that was a lot.
So, let's jump back
and kind of walk
through the things
we've showed so far.
So, we started with
optimizing your setup
with that config file
available in that GitHub repo.
That includes a lot of
fan favorite tooling.
And then there's also that
Intelligent Terminal,
which is an experimental
experience that we're playing
with of how you can have
an agent helping you
in your terminal.
Then there's those Windows
improvements, so new Run,
leveraging the PowerToys
Command Palette architecture,
along with Vertical Taskbar.
And then we've got those
Coreutils as well.
And then, as Craig covered, the
WSL container new implementation
for having a native
container solution,
that works with your
existing container files.
And then, of course, Comfort
shell, which we just showed
with that cool btop
thing at the end.
So, that is building on Windows.
Now we're going to talk
about building for Windows
and how you can streamline
building your apps directly
on Windows that are like Win
UI apps, that sort of thing.
I think it's still me,
so I'll keep going.
So, something that we have come
out with that is intended
to make building Windows apps
a little bit easier is the
winapp CLI.
So, this is a command line
interface, also open source.
That's our jam.
Everything is on GitHub.
It's great.
But this is a single CLI
for managing Windows SDKs,
packaging, generating
app identity, manifest,
certificates, and build tools.
And you can use it to really
just jumpstart building all
of your Windows apps.
And it covers the hard part like
publishing and all that stuff.
There's a section that I wanted
to show that I am now missing.
Oh, yeah, here are some things
that having package identity
for your app unlocks.
So, this is a really great
thing to use if you want
to have package identity.
But having interactive
native notifications,
along with integration
with Explorer, taskbar,
sharesheet, that kind of thing.
And then there's also
instructions for how
to get started
with this as well.
And, of course, it's on WinGet,
because everything we
make goes on WinGet.
So, it's really easy
one-line install.
And then something
that leverages this is
the win-dev-skills.
So, this is an agent plugin,
and plugins for agents is
really just a bundle of skills,
MCP servers, custom agents,
that kind of thing.
And then they just
called it a plugin,
but it's really just all
those other things we know
in one installer.
So, this is what you can
use with your agents --
oh, there's a talk later,
you should go to that --
you can use with your agents
to build WinUI 3 and
winapp SDK apps.
So, this comes with a lot of
skills that are really helpful,
like building and running the
workflow, having WinUI design,
WinUI code review, testing,
packaging, migrating from WPF,
session report, along
with WinUI setup.
Craig Loewen: What I
like about it is it's showing
you up to date information.
Your agent doesn't
need to go out
and waste tokens on,
like, a web search.
It can directly access some
of the stuff that's not
older information either.
Kayla Cinnamon: Yes, totally.
That's a great point.
This is a really great
way to be more efficient
with your token usage.
If you already provide that
context here to your agent,
saying, hey, here's the skills,
here's how to get
all this stuff,
rather than researching WinUI
3, it's going to know all
about it with this plugin.
And I installed it by
running this long prompt.
I just paste it in Copilot
because it's a
little bit easier.
But you can also do it by
hand if that's your jam, too.
And I it might be
kind of fun to try
to build a WinUI app right now.
I don't know how long this is
going to take, so bear with me.
But I liked Craig's
MarkItDown app.
I think we could try
to build it again.
Craig Loewen: That's okay.
You can steal my idea.
That's fine.
Kayla Cinnamon: All my
ideas are original.
What do you mean?
So, I'm going to jump into
Copilot, and then we're going
to -- I already have
this plugin installed,
because I ran that long prompt.
And when you get here,
first thing you want to do
so that the agent is in the
right state is you want
to set the agent to
the WinUI-dev plugin.
So, after you install it, you're
going to get a custom agent.
So, this is going to know to
route to those skills to get all
of that WinUI, winapp
SDK goodness too.
So, we're going to set this.
So, now here you can see
I've got WinUI-dev set
as my custom agent, so
that's how you know you're
in the right place.
And then I'm going to try
to use the voice
feature of Copilot CLI.
Since I'm on stage
and everything,
I don't know how
this is going to go.
But I'm going to just yap
to Copilot really quick
to build his MarkItDown app.
So, let's see how this goes.
Let's build a native WinUI
3 app that takes any file
and converts it to Markdown.
Have it have a side-by-side
view and display the contents
of both files on each
side of the app.
Make it look prettier than
Craig's MarkItDown app,
and then do UI testing and
run it after it's done.
Cool. I'm also going to put
this into Autopilot mode.
I just switched modes
with Shift Tab.
So, you got Plan, Autopilot,
and, like, Regular.
And we're just going
to kick this off.
Enable all permissions.
This is fine.
Everything is great.
It's not like this is
my real machine, right?
Craig Loewen: Yeah.
Or it's a live demo or anything.
Kayla Cinnamon: Right.
We don't know what's
going to happen.
And I don't know if this is
going to finish, either.
But something that
comes with those skills
and that plugin is
the UI testing.
So, it's going to hopefully
build the app, deploy it,
and then it's going to do UI
testing that comes baked in,
so it's already going
to know how to do it.
And my mouse would
be bouncing around
and clicking all the buttons
and checking all the text
boxes and everything.
So, I'm going to let this run.
I did do this before.
I didn't say make it
prettier than Craig's.
So, it's not beautiful.
But I did build this WinUI
app with that prompt, well,
different prompt,
but with that plugin
to kind of do the same thing.
And it worked on the first
try, which was awesome.
Craig Loewen: What's great is
it's using all the modern tools,
right, the modern buttons, etc.
Kayla Cinnamon: Right.
This is truly a
WinUI 3 component,
along with the text
box and everything,
and this browse file
button and all of that.
And then we got to talk
about PowerToys, too.
I'm just shoehorning this in
because I love PowerToys.
But they just added
this new utility.
It's grab and move.
So, I have, I don't know,
50 tabs open on Edge.
Don't judge me.
I'm one of those many tab
people, not many Windows people.
So, I can never grab the
task bar or the title bar,
because my tabs are in the way.
So, grab and move lets you just
hold alt and you can just click
from anywhere, and you're just
dragging the whole thing around.
So, it makes it a little bit
easier, which is awesome.
So, I'm going to let this run.
Hopefully, it'll build
in the next 25 minutes.
We're going to see.
But I think now would be a
really good time, we're talking
about building apps,
and what comes
with that is maybe having
more performance optimization
with those apps, especially
with compilation.
So, I'm going to hand
it over to Jianye.
We're going to pull
up a slide first,
because he's got some
great stuff to show us.
Our slides.
Craig Loewen: Must
be the old one.
Kayla Cinnamon: This
is our old slides.
We don't have a slide.
I'm so sorry.
We're just going
to leave this up.
You go.
Jianye Lu: So,
without performance,
without performance
on Windows --
[inaudible]
Kayla Cinnamon: Can you move
your mic up a little higher?
Jianye Lu: How about now?
No? How about if I just move it
a little bit?
Kayla Cinnamon: Do
you want my mic?
Can I hold mine to you?
Jianye Lu: Okay.
It's working now.
So, if you ever work on, say,
performance on Windows,
you must have heard about a
profile-guided optimization
called PGO there.
The basic idea is just to
collect the actual, say,
executable running and sample
the data, where it goes,
which part will be executed, and
feed that into the compiler,
so that compiler would do a
better job about optimizing it
when you're spitting out
the binary code set.
So, we've heard, say, good
performance number improvements
from the PGO, say 5%, 10%.
The benefit is very real,
but the cost is a little bit
hindering the adoption among the
ISV, like you hear.
The two major things that we
heard about is that, one,
it requires some
instrumentation,
which means some extra
code in your app there.
You need to do that.
Second, when you run that,
when you build that,
there will be an extra fork
in your build pipeline there.
And not everyone is a fan
about extra things to mess
with your build
pipeline on that one.
And last, but not the least,
when you run the instrument
to build, usually,
it's very slow.
So, it's not actually mimicking
what the end user will see,
making the quality of a profile
questionable on that one.
So, this is where the SPG,
or the sample-based PGO,
come in to rescue you.
Instead of using the app
code instrumentation,
it's actually using the hardware
counters, very lightweight
from -- you can use your release
view to actually run that
and use the hardware counters
to collect the profile,
so that you can enjoy the
same performance benefit,
but without all those friction
that we just talked about then.
So, the impact is
really, really real.
We work with Adobe Photoshop
team there, and they try it,
and they're seeing up to
20% of the improvement
in the real workflow,
some of the CPU
around workflow on that one.
So, in the next few minutes,
I'm going to show you how
to apply the SPGO end to end.
Unfortunately, I cannot
show that source code
from the Photoshop there, so I
have to build something myself.
Kayla Cinnamon: Yeah, Clint --
Craig Loewen: Thank you, Clint.
Kayla Cinnamon: --
as the mic holder.
Thanks, Clint.
Yeah. Nice.
All right.
Let's put you up.
Here we go.
Jianye Lu: So, on the left,
you're seeing a sample code
that I'm going to use here.
It's just a stack-based virtual
machine calculating the
Fibonacci series,
that one there.
You will see all the sample
code once we publish the repo
on that one, so don't
worry about that one.
But I want to draw
your attention
to something here,
the switch op.
So, this is just running
every single operator
of your virtual machine step.
Okay. So, you see the switch
here, which means it will jump,
based on the operator, it
will jump from here to there.
And as you can imagine,
in a stack, actually,
a lot of the branching
can be very predictable,
and while the others is
rarely used, because there's
so many loops on that one there.
So, this is where
the PTO and SPG
are really good at optimizing.
Okay. Now let's
do it end to end.
First step, let's just build it.
No fancy thing, no SPGO, just
the compiler optimizations
for things like that one.
Craig Loewen: Clint
is the fourth speaker
for our talk, actually.
Kayla Cinnamon: Yeah.
Jianye Lu: So, I need a
favor from you, Kayla.
So, can you document
the runtime here,
what the baseline look like?
Kayla Cinnamon: Three seconds.
Three seconds.
Jianye Lu: Almost three seconds.
That's the baseline.
No SPGO, no optimization so far.
Now this is the
first step you need
to do is just to
compile your code.
As you compare the original
one and this one here,
everything the same, except
there's less SPGO here.
So, you are not actually
optimizing anything yet,
because you don't
have any sample yet,
but it's telling the compiler,
I'm going to apply SPGO.
Now prep your executable,
PDPs and everything,
because you will need
that information
to consume the SPD file
later on that one.
So, just run it.
Okay. Yeah, it comes out and
say, hey, the SPD is not found.
True, because we haven't
fed anything yet.
Okay. Next one, I think many of
you are familiar with the xperf,
run something, and
then xperf again.
So, this is a traditional way
you capture the ETL traces
and build a lot of the
profiling about that one there.
You will see here,
there's a lot of numbers
and speech or whatever.
Don't worry about it now.
So, you will go.
There is a tutorial at the end,
and you can go and see, hey,
what exactly -- how is
your one coming in here?
But believe me, this
is one for the xpert
to collect the hardware
counters, which will be used
for the PGO optimization.
Okay. I just run
everything here.
Kayla Cinnamon: Should be fine.
Jianye Lu: Okay.
Stop the xperf here.
One thing, as you may notice,
we are just running
the release build
to no instrumentation,
nothing fancy.
It's just how your end user
will actually run your
executable here.
That's what we are
collecting the data from.
Next up, now you
have the ETL traces
with all the information here.
Let's abstract those
information and then put it
in the SPD file there, so that
the compiler can understand
what's going on in that one.
And this is the Step 1, and the
Step 2 here is actually convert
the SPT into the SPD file,
which will be directly
fed to the compiler.
Why don't we just combine these
two into one single step?
Why have two steps here?
The reason is for a lot of the
big software, there are many,
many important workflows.
Some of them are benchmarks.
Some of them are
user interaction.
There are quite a few things
you want to optimize together.
So, by splitting them into
several things like this one,
for each xperf, say,
capturing the ETL,
you can capture one thing.
So, one workflow for
one ETL for one SPT.
And you can do several
times in parallel.
And at the end, you can
combine all those SPT signals
information into one
single profile data,
the SPD, into that one.
Okay. Did I do that now?
Yes, SPD here.
Okay. And this is the last step.
Craig Loewen: I'm
ready for fireworks.
Kayla Cinnamon:
More terminal fire.
Craig Loewen: When it
is lighting on fire?
Jianye Lu: It's coming.
Yeah, I promise you.
So, when you rebuild
with the profile data,
everything is exactly the
same as you did before,
except for the last
step here is that, hey,
now I have the
profile data at hand.
Feed it to the compiler.
And, again, that's the
last step you have here.
And then build yet
another executable there.
How do we know whether
it works or not?
You can't tell until
you run something here.
Now it's optimized build.
How long does it take?
Kayla Cinnamon: Two seconds.
Jianye Lu: Two seconds.
Okay. And the original
baseline is --
Kayla Cinnamon: Three seconds.
Jianye Lu: So, without
bringing up a calculator,
I can tell you it's almost 33%
improvement by just running
up all these kind
of things here.
So, of course, your mileage
may vary because the app code,
the quality of your
samples, the hardware
and everything like that one.
But we heard reports from the
ISVs somewhere between 5 to 15%
of performance
improvement by just going
through this step here.
So, you can see what
actually really matter.
It starts from Step 2 here.
And then we profile, and
then we convert it to SPD,
and we build again
with the profile data.
And that's a whole end-to-end
applied to your application.
That's how it works here.
So, we talk about the 20%
improvement from Adobe.
And they really like it, because
that means not just a benchmark
number is better, but that's
more responsive and out
of the way when their users are
using the Photoshop on Windows.
That one there.
Besides the performance
number, they also see
that this is a rethinking
about how they think
about optimization there.
Previously, they did a
lot of low-level tunings
and doing this and doing that.
Yes, that will give
you something.
But the SPG will jump in and
say this is more a scalable
and sustainable way to do that.
It's about, hey, this
is a whole procedure,
and they already very
naturally integrate this one
into their product build
pipeline, because,
as you can see, it's
not intrusive at all.
There are several small
things you need to do,
but it's not forking
an instrument
to build other things, that one.
And they see that, and they
love that, and they are going
to release the SPD optimized
version to the public
in the coming days there, so
that everyone, the customers
on Windows, you'll be able
to see the benefit yourself.
One more tip that Adobe want
to share with all of us.
When you see, hey,
now we have 33%.
But is that the end?
What happened if
I change my code?
Because this is a product code.
It is a commercial product code.
They keep evolving every year.
Even if your code
doesn't change at all,
your customers may
use it differently.
Sometimes they use this one,
and later they must reach
the other one there.
The way to think about SPD,
this is not a one-shot thing.
This is an iterative thing.
You see, you do
this one pass here.
Oh, the code changed, or
the customer changes there.
Go back to number three here.
Run the new scenario,
run your new executable,
and collect the profile
again, refresh your profile,
and feed it back
to your optimizer.
You keep doing that
again and again.
Again, this could be easily part
of your build pipeline already.
And this is the way you
keep evolving your code
and the optimized results
as your code evolves
and as your user
evolves, that one there.
So I hope, in the past few
minutes, you agree with me,
this is not just a demo.
It's reshaping how you
think about optimization,
think about shaping -- how
you think about optimization
for the user experience for
your customers on that one.
And this is something.
You can go back home
tonight and start applying
to your product there and let
us know how they work for you.
And that's the fun story.
Kayla Cinnamon: That's awesome.
Craig Loewen: Nice.
Kayla Cinnamon: Yeah,
33% performance boost
on compilation, which is great.
And you built your app, then
trained a profile on it,
and then rebuilt the
app with that profile.
And that's where that
boost came from.
Jianye Lu: Exactly.
Everything in 10 seconds.
That's how Kayla
summarizes everything.
Craig Loewen: That's why
you're keynote material.
Yeah, I see it.
Kayla Cinnamon: They
only gave me 10 seconds.
Sweet. That was awesome.
Thank you, Jianye.
So, I think one of the last
things we want to cover --
also, my app did build, and
then it did all the UI testing,
and then it finished.
So, very cool.
Very cool.
Looks like this.
Still not as pretty as
Craig's, but what can you do?
But actually, speaking of Craig,
I'm going to hand it back
to him, because there's more
things with WSL containers
that you tease at the beginning
that I think we should cover.
Craig Loewen: Yeah, so
let's talk about that API.
Kayla, you've inspired me.
I want to make my own MarkItDown
app that's on Windows as well.
And so, I want to use
an API on Windows.
I want to take all that awesome
Linux container code that I had
and just build it into a
Windows app, and I don't want
to rewrite everything.
So, if you take a look on
the left side of my screen,
I have this great Containerfile.
I have all my Linux
code sitting here.
And I've made that as
part of a project.
So, this lives inside
of a C# project.
And in the C# project,
I went to the .csproj.
And let me zoom up a little bit.
I've added a WSL Containers
NuGet package right here.
And then I've defined
that exact same container
that I ran in the CLI earlier.
So, I said, here's what
you want to call it.
Here's where you can find it.
And then here's where I
want you to output it.
And now, as part of dotnet
build and dotnet run,
it will automatically
build that container.
Whenever I edit that, it will
just automatically make it part
of the build process, so I
don't have to think about it.
It truly is part
of my source code.
And I can go and run dotnet run,
and it will build
and run this app.
And so, I went ahead and created
the same MarkItDown app,
but this time I did
it fully in WinUI.
So, it looks nice and modern.
And really, the big takeaway
here, while this is building,
is this looks exactly
like a Windows app.
In fact, if I didn't tell you
that this was running Linux
in the back end, you would
not know, which is fine.
That's great.
There are a lot of customers who
want to be able to use the power
of Linux or don't even know that
they need the power of Linux,
and they don't want
to know about it.
For example, my mom and
dad don't need to know
that they're doing some great
Linux stuff in the background.
They just need to
run powerful apps.
So, let's take a look
at that same receipt
that I put in earlier.
Well, here we go.
It goes in the Windows app and
does the exact same rendering,
which is pretty great.
And so, I've made this log here
that would show how quickly
things start up or shut down.
If I go and run this app
again, I'll watch that,
and you can see the speed
that we're starting
up that container.
It basically takes about two
and a half seconds is how
long we're benchmarking
from a cold start.
And so, it's going and
initializing the session.
And then it will start
up the container.
And then it started.
And then now it's running
the Linux code inside of it.
So, then it executed
my Python service.
And all of this is powered by,
if I go to my task manager,
I can see that I have
a new process here.
That MarkItDown service
runs in its own WSL VM.
So, it's the exact
same VM technology
that powers your WSL distros.
We're now applying it to Linux
containers running as part
of a Windows application.
So, each Windows app
gets its own WSL VM.
And you can run as
many containers
as you want inside of it.
And this wouldn't be a demo
without taking a
look at the code.
So, we for sure have to go see
how we're actually doing this.
And as you can see, it's just
some C# code that's not
too long.
I'm able to go in
here and say, hey,
please start a new
session for me.
That starts the virtual machine
and with these CPU
and memory count.
And then I can start that.
I can pull a specific image.
In this case, I'm
running that locally.
And where it's really powerful
is I can configure this
to have exactly what
options I need.
So, in this case, I said
I want only port 8000
to be mapped over,
so that I'm exposing
that API that I used before.
And you can add
other options here,
like you can do volume mounting,
for example, to say, hey,
I want to be able to run
or access only specific
Windows folders.
Or you can even do
things like, hey,
I want to give this
access to my GPU.
And so, super powerful
way that runs.
And when it's all
closed and done,
all of those resources
are cleaned up.
You can see the
VM has gone away.
So, it works just
like any other app.
The last thing I'd want to
show is we're also improving
the ecosystem.
So, we're really trying to make
this a very comprehensive
end-to-end story of developing
with containers wherever
you are, API or CLI.
So, we're doing fun things
like if you go to --
there's a project, lazywslc.
You can get a very nice
TUI demo or TUI interface
for all of your containers.
So, you can go ahead and take
this as a nice dashboard.
On top of that, this
will also be supported
with dev containers.
So, if you do commands like
attach to running container,
reopening container,
or use it in VS Code,
WSL container will be
supported there as well.
And then last but not least,
for our WSL container demos,
we also wanted to highlight
an amazing partner
that we've been working with.
So, we've been working
with the MOONRAY team.
They're a team that builds a
super powerful Linux-based
rendering engine.
And that is used to
render tons of movies
that you might be aware
of, like The Bad Guys 2
or The Wild Robot, which I'm a
big fan of, as I love robots.
And so, this is a team that has
all of their code in Linux
and is open source, fully
open source, just like WSL.
And they want to bring
this awesome tool
to Windows users to easily use.
Well, how do you bridge that gap
and make it production ready?
That's where we've been able to
work together on taking a look
at the Windows subsystem
for Linux containers.
And so, I can go ahead and
take a quick look here.
I have a demo app of their code.
So, I have the
WSLC-Moonray folder.
And I have built this
and created moonray.exe.
So, that's very obviously
a Windows executable.
And I'm also inputting
inputs to this.
And if you note the backslash,
these are definitely Windows
files that I'm giving in.
And these are Windows
files of .rdla,
which are basically
render inputs.
And then I'm asking it, hey,
could you please render
out this jpeg for me.
And when I run this, it's
going to run exactly the same
as what I showed earlier,
just a command line version.
And I've shown that these --
I've kept in this debug
information here.
So, you can see that that
was the machine starting.
Now we have the actual
rendering happening.
It's using up all of my CPU,
which is exactly what you want
to see when you're
doing a nice render.
And then once it's done, it
will perfectly shut down,
clean up the VM.
And I can go ahead
and take a look
at the beautiful
image we rendered,
which was this lovely
orange coffee maker.
And so, that was all done
exactly as a Windows CLI.
Right? It's .exe.
It was all Windows
inputs and outputs.
I opened a Windows file.
But everything, all of
the code that was running
in the back end, beyond
just the integration code
for the API, was fully Linux.
So, something we're
really, really excited
to see what you could do
with, from AI containers,
AI containerization,
to cloud to local.
I think there's tons of
exciting opportunities.
Kayla Cinnamon: Cool.
Sweet. Yeah, that was great.
And we're running out of time
here, so I'm going to kind
of wrap it up with
one last note.
On our team, we've been working
on all these open-source tools,
and we've been working on
open source for years.
And, actually, Clint had the
great idea of exporting the list
of contributors of everyone
who's contributed to Terminal,
WSL, WinUI, PowerToys.
And the file is
16,000 lines long.
So, we've had over 16,000 open
source contributors on all
of our projects, which is huge.
So, we want to
truly, truly thank
everybody that's contributed
to everything that
we've been working on,
because the products
would not be
where they are today
without y'all.
Craig Loewen: I should
have made my name ZZZZZ,
so I show up.
I should have.
Wasted opportunity.
Kayla Cinnamon: And, of course,
we're very excited
about Coreutils.
So, we thought it'd be fun to
do a little Grep with one
of our friends, Nora, who's been
a really awesome contributor,
especially for PowerToys.
So, want to give a huge shout
out to our contributors
and Nora as well.
But we want to just thank
everyone who's made these
products shape up to
where they are today.
So, here's that slide with all
the links that I told you about.
So, we're going to maybe
recap a little bit,
but we talked about config file.
We had that Comfort shell
and that same repo,
SPGO that Jianye covered.
This link will show you how to
run that with your own projects
and get that performance
boost with compilation.
And then, of course, there's
Intelligent Terminal
and its own repo.
The WinApp CLI and Win Dev
Skills have their own repos.
And PowerToys also
has its own repo.
So, if you want to get
started with any of these,
this is the slide to grab.
And with that, we
can jump into Q&A.
Thank you so much, everybody,
for listening and watching.
And feel free to scan
this, because it's --
I think it's important.
So, thank you, everybody,
and we're happy
to answer any questions.
Craig Loewen: Thank you.
[ Applause ]